Represents self reflexivity or cyclicality,
especially in the sense of something constantly recreating itself,
the eternal return and other things perceived as cycles.
Then begin a new,
as soon as they end the mythical Phoenix has a similar similar symbolism.
So now we know what it's called.
We have,
or Boris.
Yes.
Something along those lines symbolizes the cycle of life.
It's fascinating shit.
Now we know and smoked serpent is the name of your band and it's a,
is there a website yet?
It's smoke syrup and.com no,
but you can hear a couple of songs on leave that name reverb.
I should get,
I should get on reverbnation.com/smoke so got a couple of songs,
Bro.
You better get smoked Turkey dark cloud.
I might not even be available.
You better do it for this video.
Thank you very much for being on the podcast.
Eddie Cooler hanging out with you today.
You're welcome horn.
She always a good time buddy.
Anytime.
Bye guys.
File 80 on Twitter.
Eddie Bravo and red ban.
Red Bin.
This is a video of me playing pool.
This is not a dumb man.
This is what I'm interested in.
I'm interested in not even just playing pool,
watching myself play pool.
There's a rare video of me running out,
especially when I call it,
and then I had to go to the,
to the other room and deal with the little ones because they called them in the
middle of it.
He was like,
that's the role.
It's the Joe Thailand
Very Rachel episode.
Watch that video.
I love that.
But when I was days,
by the way,
when you left,
like where's my phone?
I don't know.
Ari's last show,
he fucking stole my phone for a minute.
He kept going.
I was like this somewhere.
I'm just like showing
me,
I'm terrified.
I want to listen to my material and go over it like a real professional.
But Ari just playing this a little yucky up game.
Black Cock like same trigger,
but talk about what you do with Sam,
Tripoli,
Tripoli.
I in all those guys have this thing where they,
you try to steal the other person's phone.
Yeah,
you're right.
I like Black Hawks on your Twitter and your Facebook and like,
like Jason's mom the other day or get it to Jason's mom or something like that.
They get it to Jason's mom.
Whoa.
She's loving.
She,
she doesn't like Black Hawk at all.
How Liberals?
Mom.
Yeah.
Teams.
Mom's a lesbian.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's fascinating.
His whole life he knew it.
Did he?
What was it they they adopt or they find a sperm donor?
I think it's his real mom and then she just married someone later.
Yeah.
I think that's what it is.
And his,
he has a real sister too.
Yeah.
That's it.
And show the mother bread for procreation purposes,
but essentially lesbian.
Yeah.
What is your take on like this Chaz Bono situation?
Isn't that fascinating?
Incoming?
Yeah.
Becoming a man when he was raised by a woman who was super duper famous and then
chooses somewhere along the line to to,
to change sex and become a man.
When you think about that shit,
I think there are some people with their mind's fucked up in a way that we don't
understand and I think some things went wrong.
It's the middle of war without thumbs,
so maybe somebody is born with the wrong sex and you just know it.
Just know it.
Right.
I feel like a man.
You're probably going to feel like I have vagina,
man,
dog.
I think it's awesome.
We can fix that shit now,
man.
Dog.
Yeah,
I think it is.
I heard that sound.
I totally agree with you,
man.
I think,
you know,
like we were talking about before,
I have a thyroid problem.
My thyroid doesn't work good.
You know,
some people's brains firing correctly.
Some people were really probably their chemical makeup.
They should've been a boy or a girl.
There's no preconceived derogatory things that have to do with the fibroid.
Lucky for you to want to go.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
If you don't want to go through a sex change,
man,
that's like God damn commitment.
I got to think you're really telling the truth.
You must be like,
I'm not enough.
For a long time.
It's hacked off and they've got to grow me a cock.
There'll be eventually they'll be able to grow your cock right now.
They can't now think grow an ear on a mice though.
I worked for,
I worked for a transsexual,
preop transsexual,
but I was in a law firm.
You work the file room.
Holy Shit.
He only likes fucking straight men.
Whoa.
What did it feel like?
Yeah,
he said he would have to go to face them,
so we'd have to put his leg on top of them.
Oh my God.
How'd you get a straight man to fuck you?
Because I'm a woman.
Why wouldn't they
or they fuck him?
Fuck him in the ass and do they know they're fucking,
I know.
They just like,
no,
I know you're real.
You're a woman or your heart or something.
Oh my God.
I have a friend who is gay and he says that gay guys suck his Dick.
All the tar straight guys rather on silent.
Yeah.
He says he gets straight guys to suck his dick.
He says they,
they act curious a bar somewhere and he'll tell them there that he's gay and
then there'll be curious and before you know they're blowing him.
He said,
it happens all the time.
I'm like,
that's not a fucking straight guy man.
You're saying you've got a straight guy to suck your Dick.
You got a gay guy who was in the closet to blow you.
It's not really a straight guy.
You met him at a gay bar
for sure.
There's certain people have degrees of gay and um,
you know how we talked about yesterday,
this new girl that you're dating,
it's got you so excited and you could fuck all the time.
It's like you connect to her and this,
this straight sex.
It's like there's a vibe between the two of units,
like a powerful straight sex vibe.
I think some dudes can get dudes to be gay.
Like you might have been really happy with being straight and having a wife and
children and you know,
and having like some sort of a weird,
none exciting sex life and less,
you met the right gay guy along the way.
It turned your ass and made you be a super gay freakazoid,
which is very possible.
You know,
if you just,
I think part of the right person,
the right stage of your life.
And I'm not saying you cause you couldn't and I'm not saying you can,
but you can be on the offense.
I think those people are already like probably bisexual,
but hiding it.
Cause it's
like that joke that I used to do about,
um,
about people.
There's somewhere out there,
there's someone who could talk some people into suck in the deck.
That is just the way it is.
And it's,
it's,
it's a fact that some people can just be tricked and it doesn't necessarily mean
they're gay.
And I think that's one of the reasons why so many people are afraid of gay
people.
What they're afraid of.
It's being tricked by a superior intellect that happens to be homosexual.
And then actually,
you know,
that guy is shooting loads and your asshole.
Well,
it's terrifying for,
for retards.
Whoops,
Don people,
it's hard.
No,
ladies and gentlemen,
we need me no harm.
Okay.
We're just out here trying to have a good time and trying to learn and grow as
humans.
We're doing a lot together with Brian.
Read ballets,
college boy.
Hello.
Hi.
Come on man.
What's happening?
This is a gloss my man.
How are you doing?
Do you know what information?
Alien.
So Hey Brian,
video of them quick changes.
The door rep is Veronica.
Giorgio pleasure.
How are you?
You're from ancient aliens.
Yeah.
He never seen the shootout with the crazy hair.
I have.
No,
but I liked the hair
look so weird that
started rolling.
We got to get the fuck out of here.
I'm quite sure it gets weird.
The trick is to
build the city
that's going on right now,
right?
Doug Benson,
am I correct?
I have a feeling it's all in our minds.
I have a feeling of the whole alien experience.
There's all psychedelic chemicals including all the shit that was created and
nobody could figure out what's the pyramids or all these other crazy structures.
I think that you guys were down on the money when you talk about ancient
civilizations going to talk about like Graham Hancock can shit,
but there was some super advanced civilization,
but I don't think they got it.
I think they got drugs and I think the drugs are the aliens.
And I think when you take those trucks,
you contact alien.
And I'm not bullshitting you.
Take DMT,
Bro.
I think you're contacting the elements.
I really fucking do.
I felt raped of mentally but in the best way ever.
When I came back to that,
like someone just saw through me and sees me for this really insignificant like
style of creature,
you know,
really like mundane and really easy to solve and figure out.
It just exposed me and um,
expose me to infinite wisdom that was impossible to grasp.
But it did it all on some sort of a language.
I think that is the alien.
I think the alien is psychedelic chemicals.
And we know if there's a great history of human use of psychedelic chemicals
dating back thousands and thousands of years,
mushrooms draw on cave walls,
you know,
all the evidence of,
of ritualistic use of cannabis that takes thousands and thousands of years BC.
So if we know that they knew about all this shit,
we know that they knew about the avenue,
the miscarriage mushroom and,
and you know,
and,
and the Amazon,
they've been doing Iowasca for thousands and thousands of years.
They don't even know how long because they don't even write it down.
They just always have done it.
That's the alien,
Bro.
That's the alien.
The alien is these compounds and the aliens are real because these top pounds,
I'll allow you to get to this other place.
They allow you to communicate with something and that's why all these people
were abducted in the middle of the night.
Man,
they're abducted in the middle of the night because that's when your brain is
producing DMT.
That's when your brain spruce and psychedelic chemicals and when your brain
produces those chemicals,
it opens that gateway and you communicate with these fucking things.
We just want everything real to be,
someone said this,
I think it was Terence Mckenna,
that people have a problem with something that's real,
that you can't hit with a hammer.
Right.
And I think that's a real way of putting it.
It's a real issue cause farts are real as fuck dude,
you can't wrap your hands around them but you know they're real.
Sound is real.
But we accept it because we're so used to it.
The idea that this is an invisible thing can can transmit music and harmony and
and beautiful feelings and make you fucking pumped up and you hear it,
your car singing it and what the,
what the fuck is that?
It's invisible shit and invisible shitting but it's coming for fucking
satellites down to us.
We want to think that we've got the whole world figured out.
We want to think that we know what's real and what's here and that all the
weekends sense is all it is there.
And I say,
fuck that.
I said that's ridiculous.
And I say if you look at some shit that your own brain produces and this shift
that your own brain producers,
producers,
profound visions and clinical experiences,
I got to think that that shit is the alien.
That's what it is.
It's not dudes and metal crafts are coming from outer space.
It's fucking fine that you mix with a leave and the boil it fire and the Amazon
for fucking 10 hours and then you drink the shit and go on a ride with the
flying serpents fucking twist around you and they're all made out of light,
you know,
and they teach you about the spirit world and your ancestors and that everyone's
around you all the time,
always and forever.
They just move in and out at different.
That's some fucking to the sticker thing under your ass.
That's all.
Everybody's crazy to all the people you're talking to you on your show are
fucking crazy.
Got To show that everyone's misunderstood and everyone's crazy and they both had
experiences.
But what you need to do is get them high on DMT and they'd go,
that's it.
That's it.
I'll show you a video channel and just smoke some shit.
And when I'm bored,
you understand what's happening here.
It's not here.
That's why you're never going to see them all that shit flying over London.
You're never going to see him.
So that's what I'm thinking about aliens.
Unfortunately,
that kills the whole show.
That was that whole shot.
So let's keep speculating.
Thank you.
I'm coming out before I come up,
I got a bunch of new friends.
I got Doug Benson in their house
and as far as going to bring up is in my opinion,
the funniest human on the face of the earth.
You might know him from the longest yard.
You might know him from my podcast.
You might know.
Give it up for joing.
Kakoda
no,
Joe
[inaudible] over to you now,
right now,
but sometimes love it.
I love that.
This food open.
Fucking ridiculous.
We got to stay here a minute.
So what are you saying that the turn in the Luxor into a gay hotel.
I'm just saying the last time I stayed there I started to lot.
I was mad
shit.
Joe Login was awesome tonight in French.
He was awesome.
Awesome show.
Pay there tonight.
I'm going to say it on the air tomorrow now that'll fuck him up on it.
I started singing the shit during fucking Greenland.
What are you going to do then,
Joe?
Mr.
Seriously,
when we're on game play,
we'll play my own game.
He went,
I want to be motherfuckers.
So just Drake.
Now I don't pee and I steal Joe Spoon and I text all you fuckers are drinking
shots and I'm not even in the bathroom.
Much more exciting when that's uncircumcised to how,
Oh,
that's a horse.
That is bad ass.
They sell four sticks.
Did Not want it goes right into your,
yeah,
your dirty fucking mouth bitch.
Fucking kind.